علامات حددها العلم يمكن من خلالها كشف ما
اذا كان الشخص كاذبا او محتالا منها ان
نقروا على القدم غالبا ما تكون علامه على
الانزعاج او نفاذ الصبر وقد يؤدي النقر
على القدمين ايضا الى تسريع قرارك ما قد
يخدم مصلحته المتلاعب وايضا حك الذقن
لمحاوله اظهار عدم اليقين غالبا يستخدم
لاجبار الاخرين على الاستسلام على سبيل
المثال ان يظهر لك انه لن يستطيع القيام
بامر ماء ليخدعك كي تقوم انت بالمهم نيابه
عنه فركوا اليدين والرقبه من الممكن ان
تدل على التوتر او الشعور بالدم عند
استغلال شخص اخر كذلك وميض العين وحركاتها
فالمحتال يمكن ان ينظر في العين لتحديد
مائده كانت الضحيه تنطلي عليها الخدعه او
الكذب كذلك تغيير اوضاع الجسم فاذا شعرت
ان شخصا ما او للسيطره عليك فابدا في
الانتباه الى عدد مرات تغير وضع الجسم
يمكن ان يكون قد تم استدراجه الى حالتي
رضوخ